THAT NIGHT SCORING A LATE ONE
WITH 90 SECONDSDS MILLER, A DECT
BUT NOT LATELY AND YOU SAW THAT
FIRST IT IS LUKE
SCHENN WHO IS PINCHING IN, WITHE
SUBSTITUTIONS AS THE GAME,
SNARING THAT ONE OUT OF THE AIR.
>> John G.: WELLAND HE COMES OUD
NOW BANKING THAHAOULD
JUST START WITH THE ENTIRE
SECOND UNIT.F
THE RUSH, ZIBANEJAD, A
IN TIME AND HAVE A LOOK HERE
HIT AND BOBBLING THAT PUCK, ON N
SPORTSNET PACIFIC AND NOW ON
FRIDAY.
0-4,
>> John G.: EVERYONE LOOKING UP
HERE AT THE IN, WITH
THE GLOVE, PEARSON, FROM BEHIND
TYORKIN HAS
BEEN THIS YEAR YOU GET BOUNCES
JUST LIKE THIS,
IT HIT POOLMAN.
>> John G.: HIT THE STICK,
THE POOLMAN.
THIS TIME, BEHIND TROUBA, JUST T
THAT HANDLE, THE CANUCKS NOW
TWO-ON-O-O THE CANUCKS HAVE LOWD
CENTRES, MILLER SCORES.
[ Horn ]
[ J.T. MILLER, GETTING
BODY POSITION AND H H AND IT IS
GARLAND TO PODKOLZIN, SCORES!
[ HTHERE.
AND WHAT A GREAT SHOTT PAD SAVE,
BACKHANDER, MILLER IS, OFF OF HA
WHERE IT IS AND LOOK AT HIM
THDISH OFF, GARLAND, A MOVE HER,
AND THE PUCK CENTRES, PANARIN,
AND KREIDER IN FRONT MISSES THE
HOCKEY, 101 ANDAT PASS, GOT PASG
THE CLOCK TO MacSURE THAT
THEY WILLOW THE GOALIES HAVING
SWITCHED ENDS AND MILLER, AN
INTERCEPT.
HERE HE COMES, HUGHES THE GLOVED
MILLER, ONCE AGAIN, SHOT,
SCORES!